this is one of the most outrageous and
also
chilling stories about press freedom and
treatment of activists and journalists
uh the belarusian or belarusian
president alexander lukashenko ordered a
fighter jet to escort a passenger flight
operated by ryanair
to the ground in minsk belarus
so that a specific passenger on that
flight
rahman pratasivic an exiled critic
of lukashenko could be arrested now you
might be asking
well what was pratosovich doing
flying to belarus knowing
that an arrest could be what is going to
happen
at the tail end of it well the answer is
that he actually was not
that is not actually what he was doing
this was a ryanair flight flight number
4978
uh ryanair is a european low-cost
carrier which
is not exactly a pleasure to fly on i
will tell you the flight was scheduled
to go from athens greece to vilnius
lithuania
but it just so happens that this flight
flies
over bella russian airspace and belarus
launched a fighter jet to intercept the
plane
have it land in minsk belarus every
passenger was removed
one explanation that was apparently
given although i'll get back to this
is that there was a quote potential
security threat on board
so bella russian authorities have
everybody get off the plane they
check everything and they say great news
everything's fine
after five hours on the ground it was a
false alarm everybody can leave
everybody gets back on the plane but not
really everybody one passenger wasn't
there
when they reboarded after the five hours
on the ground in minsk
rahman pratasivic was not there
was taken into custody and did not
re-board the plane
now afterwards the ryanair flight took
off for vilnius
um and everything resumed quote as
normal
and we'll talk about ryanair's
explanation for what took place
so who is this rahman pratasivic
pratosifik is the founder of the
telegram channel nexta
which was used to organize
anti-belarusian government protests
um another similar channel critical of
the government
was also run by protosavic both are
classified as
extremists in belarus and pratosovic is
also
on a government-wanted list for
terrorism
but belarus has a strong man
authoritarian in power
who has been in power since 1994 was
abruptly inaugurated into office for the
sixth time in a row last september
following a disputed election that the
eu said was not
a legitimate election and amid mass
protests in belarus last summer
lukashenko and the state security
apparatus started
removing from the country or detaining
leading opposition
figures and now they've grounded a plane
forcibly
to take an activist off of it now
there's another really wacky part to
this story
the statement that was put out by
ryanair about the flight
makes no mention of the fact that they
were strong-armed by an authoritarian
government that has been in power for
nearly 30 years
and that one of their passengers was
taken off the flight
the ryanair press office tweeted quote
our flight
4978 has landed safely in vilnius
at 7 25 pm local time or uk time 9 25
local time here is ryanair's statement
on today's diversion to minsk airport
and when you read it
it sounds like nothing really happened
it just says um
the crew on a ryanair flight to vilnius
today were notified by belarus
about a potential security threat on
board and
were instructed to divert to the nearest
airport
that was minsk the aircraft landed
safely passengers were offloaded
security checks were completed by locals
nothing untoward was found and
authorities cleared the craft to depart
together with passengers and crew
after about oh seven hours on the ground
i had said five in minsk
the airport departed the aircraft
departed for vilnius at 1850 uk time and
landed at 1925 uk time ryanair has
notified the relevant national and
european safety and security agencies
we apologize sincerely to all affected
it's like
there wasn't someone pulled off after
the flight was escorted to land
by a fighter jet rather um it was just
uh a check and everything was fine and
no big deal and
the other thing about this that's
raising red flags is nobody's even on
the same page about what happened
story one was there was a potential
threat so the plane landed and they
checked
whether there really was a threat the
minsk airport
told russian state media ria navasti
that the plane made an emergency landing
because of an unconfirmed
bomb threat but then a spokesperson for
lithuanian airports
said to lrt national radio that the
landing was because there was a conflict
on the flight between a passenger and
one of the
of the crew members completely different
explanations now the eu and the u.s have
condemned
this arrest and how it took place this
is really
the stuff of horrors and as a passenger
i'd be furious at the delay
besides the politics flying with ryanair
is horrible and i avoid it whenever
possible now they made me have two
flights really
i'm kidding around obviously that's not
really the important thing here
this is really horrifying it is
dystopian and we're going to follow it
but are we ever going to hear from
rahman
tavik again i don't know the answer to
that and as of right now we don't know
exactly what fate awaits him
or has already uh been been carried out
against him so
scary stuff and just a bizarre uh
whitewashed sort of statement from
ryanair
and we will presumably learn more about
this as the days go on
facts do not matter when nobody pays
attention to them
bad acts don't matter when there are no
punishments or consequences for those
bad acts and that is exactly
what is happening with the trump riots
there is a new ipsos poll
which finds that 54 percent of
republicans
believe that the trump riots were led
not by violent trumpists but that the
trump riots were
actually led by violent left-wingers
trying to make donald trump look bad
which
they obviously were trump supporters
as hundreds of pages of court documents
about the now
indicted defendants now show so there is
no factual basis
for a belief that more than half of
republicans claim to have
some months ago we asked will republican
elected officials be punished
for not voting for the coveted relief
bill because that bill was so popular
and only democrats voted for it
joe biden supported it and it turns out
that a ton of republican voters think
that republican officials
did vote for it we talked about that
poll last week
a whole bunch of republican voters who
got 1400
checks believe i got this check because
of republicans even though they didn't
similarly a huge portion of republicans
simply refused to accept or have been
convinced into believing
that the trump riots of january 6
weren't really trumpists rioting but
rather left-wingers in disguise
just trying to make donald trump look
bad the poll numbers are disgusting in
terms of what they mean about the
disconnect in this country
between facts and beliefs check this out
only
29 of republicans strongly or somewhat
agree
trump was at least partially to blame
for the riots just
29 however 48 percent of republicans
believe
that the people who gathered were mostly
peaceful and then
54 percent either strongly or somewhat
agree that the riots were
actually led by left wingers trying
to make donald trump look bad and it
gets even wilder
when asked who do you think the true
president
is right now 53 percent of republicans
believe that today right now
donald trump is the true president of
the united states now strangely
three percent of democrats also believe
trump is the true president
i i'd love to speak to them uh and 22
percent of independents think that trump
is actually the president right now this
is a national
tragedy this is a national emergency of
critical thinking of tribalism of group
psychosis of all of it and more now
i do think it's really important to
mention
this is different than what we had in
the past in the past
we had partisanship we had partisan
disagreements about
did it make sense to go into iraq who
did 9 11. you had a lot of people who
watch a lot of fox news confused
thinking it was actually iraq that did 9
11. this
is now a large-scale republican slide
away from objective reality to a degree
that we've not seen in this country
before
this is it it is actually becoming
cult-like
and this is a serious real question it's
not a joke it's not an insult it's a
real question
are these republicans genuinely
delusional
in the diagnostic sense or are they
deliberately lying to pollsters about
everything
how did they lose their connection to
reality
matthew sheffield has a really good
piece in flux
about this exploring exactly this
question where he says
maybe republicans are lying to pollsters
in order to as they might see it help
the party
it might be less about republicans
literally believe
that left wingers pretending to be trump
as did the riot
but they are saying that to pollsters to
send a message that
they are with trump no matter what for
example right that would be one
possibility as to why we are seeing
these numbers in poll after poll after
after poll what do you think whatever
the explanation it's horrifying and
scary
but the practical matter is how do we
fix it and we can only fix it if we know
what the true problem is
is this a grand delusion
a group psychosis of republicans where
they actually believe
trump is literally the president right
now the riots weren't actually trumpists
despite what all the social media
accounts and
court records and all of it say it was
leftists in disguise do they literally
believe that or is it a delusion of
theirs
and are they answering polls
genuinely or in a way meant to send a
message that they are with trump no
matter what
let me know your thinking on this
because the answer
is not trivial in terms of what it means
about how we actually go about the
deprogramming
of the people that have this mass
delusion
or have decided we are going to lie in
order to send a message let me know what
you think i'm on twitter
deepakman we are just one week away from
the monday memorial day
one day membership bomb we have sadly
had a lot of people
more than i care to say hundreds and
hundreds of people cancel memberships in
the last month
for financial reasons and so we are
doing a one day membership special on on
may 31st hoping to invite a lot of those
folks back
and people who have never before been
members if you've been thinking of
getting a membership and you're just
waiting for the perfect day
the perfect day is memorial day if you
want to hear about that special
monday morning just get on my mailing
list
at davidpakman.com
the number one funding source for the
david pakman show
has been and continues to be membership
and membership
is not just a feel-good thing you get
access to the world famous bonus show
every single day just for members as
well as commercial free audio
and video feeds of the show day in
and day out you can sign up for
membership very very quickly
at joinpacman.com that's join p
a k m a n dot com if the normal prices
strike you as high
by all means use the coupon code
better21
all one word all lowercase become a
member today
remember that we are primarily supported
by members who sign up
at joinpackman.com i won't say more
about it i think everybody knows what to
do
join pacman.com as if we don't already
have enough anti-semitism to deal with
right now
radical and outrageous right-wing
congresswoman marjorie taylor-green
is comparing having to wear a mask in
the house of representatives
to the holocaust green was interviewed
by the christian broadcasting network's
david brody
on the real america's voice tv show
yes that's a real channel that's a real
show here is what
she had to say this woman is mentally
ill
you know we can look back in a time in
history where people were told to wear a
gold star
and they were definitely treated like
second class
citizens so much so that they were put
in trains and taken to gas
chambers in nazi germany and this is
exactly
the type of abuse that nancy pelosi is
talking about
well let's talk about the queen of the
house of hip there was no pushback
at all from the interviewer david brody
there
a mask mandate from mentally ill
nancy pelosi is like jews being murdered
in the holocaust according to marjorie
taylor greene now of course there's no
follow-up from the reporter
because cbn isn't journalism it's merely
propaganda and the guy really isn't a
reporter
but at the same time to say nothing is
really not an option this has to be
called out when something
from something for the greater good like
vaccination or wearing a mask during a
pandemic
is being compared to the genocide of the
jewish people
you have to call it out and say this
isn't accurate and anybody who enables
it in this case it was david brody on
the christian broadcasting network
enabling it
also must be called out the nazis didn't
order the jews
to do things that kept them safe that
wasn't what went on during the holocaust
rules established to protect health are
not the same as the systematic
extermination of a people
and of course the greater tragedy is
that this woman was elected to be a
member of congress
it's not even clear to me that marjorie
taylor green should have a driver's
license
and there's an entire political movement
that believes
she should be one of the 535 federal
lawmakers 100 senators 435 in the house
535 total
there's a movement that thinks in a
country of 331 million one of the 535
leading us at the federal level
should be her that is really really
dangerous
and this is what happens when we either
look away or we don't vote
or we don't vote in large enough numbers
i got an email from a viewer
who believes he understands how people
like marjorie taylor green
come to have a following in the first
place and the way he outlined it was
you start with years and years of fear
mongering about you know who
right years and years and years of
fearing wrong about democrats
and minorities taking advantage of
welfare programs
brown people coming here illegally and
stealing your jobs and committing crimes
all of that fear-mongering that you know
of
you combine it with sensationalist
propaganda news media
fox news oan newsmax
christian broadcasting network and then
you have underfunded education parents
who don't know anything about media
literacy so they can't teach their kids
so the kids have no place to learn it
and then
you direct at the self-centered
sort of upper middle class middle
middle-class suburbanites like green
you direct the propaganda at them absent
the education that they need
they become deranged they become
obsessed with protecting their own
status that's being threatened by
you know democrats non-existent
socialists
minorities immigrants poor people etc
they identify them as the enemies and
then in a country of 331 million people
imagine this is who ends up getting
elected as one of 435 members of the
house one of 535 members
of the house and senate uh it is a vile
and disgusting analogy
that she makes she is a vile woman and i
know that sometimes the term mentally
ill is used in jest
or as a slur but there are more and more
members of congress
referring to marjorie taylor greene as
sick or mentally ill
including aoc who actually said quote
this is a woman that's deeply unwell and
clearly needs help it seems obvious that
that's the case
some people saw what aoc said and they
said oh that's bad aoc
is stigmatizing and making fun of mental
illness
i don't see that at all at a certain
point we have to be able
to say this is not just an ignorant
person with
disgusting political views these are
ignorant political views that have been
weaponized
by some kind of mental illness and you
have enough people in this country
who either don't realize that this is an
unwell woman
uh or they don't care i don't know it
has to be okay
to propose that there is a mental
illness component when it's so obviously
what's going on but at the same time
the mental illness component doesn't
excuse the political beliefs
it's a double-edged sword calling
something mental illness when it isn't
isn't a good thing to do at the same
time excusing
bad acts because the person seems
sick or unwell we also can't be doing
that
it is a complicated issue particularly
in a country where many don't have
access to proper mental health services
or diagnostic services
and when it's heavily stigmatized and
when quite frankly i mean listen
i don't know if i'll get in trouble for
saying this um
there are lots of political beliefs some
on the left
but overwhelmingly on the right that are
delusional beliefs in the literal sense
and so when you
when you see that it actually can be
difficult to distinguish
just delusional political beliefs versus
someone who is
uh diagnosable i think with marjorie
taylor green
it's probably both and that is
increasingly what we're hearing from
people who know her
and who have been uh targeted and and by
her
like alexandria ocasio-cortez let me
know your thoughts
uh but a disgusting analogy and
comparison there
hey this you have to see pakistan
has this foreign minister named shah
mahmud qureshi
and this guy doesn't even try to hide
anti-semitic slurs
with the coded language and
sophisticated analogies and metaphors
that some try to use
to hide their anti-semitic slurs he just
drops an
anti-semitic slur that jews control the
media during the first 15 seconds of an
interview with cnn's bianna golodriga
and you just have to see this now
sadly and we'll talk about this more
later this week there has been an
explosion of anti-semitic violence
around the us
in the last few days uh since the
israeli gazan ceasefire there are random
jewish people being attacked and beaten
across the u.s
incidents being investigated in los
angeles and new york and in many other
places people being punched kicked
beaten it's insane we're going what's
going on
we're seeing it on our channel where
we're having to ban
at this point it's hundreds of people
per day it's never been this bad
it's it's been bad it's never been as
bad as in the last week
uh anti-semitic comments and we're just
banning
banning
banning people on youtube twitch
facebook reddit twitter etc etc
but this isn't random people like i
expect to get emails about jews control
the media
uh you know from bob in uh
west virginia but this is the pakistani
foreign minister
using this line so let's jump into it
this interview taking place right before
the israeli gazan ceasefire was
announced take a look
and the pakistani foreign minister joins
me now from new york mr minister thank
you so much for joining us um it has
been a very busy day
from your end do you hear any talks
about a possible cease-fire coming
anytime soon
i am convinced the tide is turning
i am convinced the public pressure
the pressure of public opinion is
mounting
and seized fire is inevitable
israel is losing out they're losing the
media
war despite their connections
they are losing the media war the tide
are their connections
deep pockets what does that mean
well they're very influential people i
mean they control media
i mean i i would call that an
anti-semitic remark
well you see the point is uh they
have a lot of influence and they get a
lot of coverage
now what has balanced that is the
citizen journalist their connections
deep pockets they control the media
i have to commend bianna golodriga
because she did something that lots of
people won't do
which is just straight up call it what
it is which is anti-semitic
there's often mincing words where the
purveyor of this stuff will use coded
language
and then the person doing the interview
also will use coded language or or mince
words in some way
he goes head first dive right into it
jews control the media with money and
influence
and she says that's an anti-semitic
comment and the foreign minister is sort
of unsure how to respond
and he kind of drifts into something
else and says well let me say this other
thing
now what's really nuts and this is
this i don't even know what to what to
call this if you look online at articles
and segments about this segment
it is riddled with even more
anti-semitic comments
saying good for the finance minister for
calling out jewish control of media
there's a huge contingent and sadly many
are on the american left
who loved what the foreign minister said
it's sad
but it's seen as more acceptable to be
openly anti-semitic at this time because
of the israeli-palestinian situation
which of course
relates to israeli foreign policy which
i find terrible right
i've called out how long have i been
against israeli foreign policy and the
netanyahu administration i don't know
and the reason that there's general
anti-semitism towards random global jews
is because of the anti-semitic trope
that any jewish person around the world
holds a dual loyalty to israel and we've
talked about that many times before now
by the way
pakistani twitter was cheering this
as if the finance minister the foreign
minister
did the most heroic thing anybody could
have done finally putting the jews in
their place for control of media
as if it's a new and unstated truth that
he's finally willing to say
pakistani twitter users have been
calling the finance minister courageous
brave wise it is jarring
it's not altogether surprising i saw one
nice response to this clip
which was an image of pictures
of jewish elected officials with stars
of david
american elected officials with stars of
david identifying them as jewish it was
a really nice touch you can imagine so
anyway
nice job by bianna golodriga she's
getting absolutely destroyed for this by
pakistani twitter and by others
it's all become quite more brazen lately
i don't remember it ever being as bad as
in the last week
the we we we don't have enough
moderators on any of our platforms to
actually keep
up with the anti-semitism that has
exploded here and uh we'll have a little
more about this
on the show's instagram make sure you're
following us
following us there at david pakman show
and follow me on instagram
at david.pacman we'll take a quick break
next there's somebody now you might be
able to guess who
proposing a real insurrection
not like the one from january 6. that's
after the break
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners and
one way to keep us going is through
patreon
where you can pledge as little as one
dollar per month
or as much as you want at patreon.com
show great perks and benefits as well
read about him
as if things weren't a tinderbox already
fox news propagandist tucker carlson is
now suggesting
a real insurrection on his program now
the term real insurrection is of course
tucker playing coy
with the january 6 trump riots tucker
and others claim
that january 6 was not really an
insurrection
and when they say that it's never
totally clear if they mean
it's not really an insurrection because
it failed or
it's not an insurrection because it
wasn't really meant to be an
insurrection in any case we've talked
before about stochastic terrorism and
this idea that with a large enough
audience
even subtly if you put an idea into
people's minds
someone becomes likely to go and
actually do the thing
uh if you subtly put the idea in an
audience of a hundred people to go and
kill someone um
it's not super likely that someone's
really going to do it but if your
audience is a thousand or ten thousand
or a million or ten million
once it gets to be a large audience that
subtle idea
becomes more and more likely to actually
influence someone in the crowd to do and
go and do the thing you're subtly
suggesting they do in this clip
tucker's not even floating the idea
subtly he's just saying
why don't we have a real insurrection
and why does he want one
well because of misstatements that his
guest
the mayor of uvalde texas don mclaughlin
tells about immigration these are lies
about immigration and it makes tucker
say
what about a real insurrection over this
take a look that the people coming north
from
latin america central america a lot of
cases are aware that there's a new
administration the united states and the
policies are different
oh most definitely they're telegraphing
it down there uh
what do you when you see t-shirts with
people say bye and let me in
biden let me and they're all over i mean
you know it's telegraphed back down
there one of them comes over and they'll
tell you
as soon as i get over and get through
i'm calling back home and i'm selling 10
more to come
that i got in come on we're sending a
message that hey
the border's open come on in do what you
want i mean
why aren't we enforcing the laws that
are on the book that are already on the
book that says
you can't cross that border illegally or
whatever but yet we're going to reward
you with
putting you in a nice hotel or or give
you a 1400
visa card debit card that you can use
while you're here in the states
you know till you get established or
whatever and how many times they
replenish what you mean giving
a 14 visa debit card i haven't been able
to confirm this yet
but i have been told that they're giving
you these immigrant families are in
these hotels
they're giving them a 14 i mean a 1400
visa card
if they can why don't we have a real
insurrection at some point like why
why would we put up with this well in my
opinion you're closer than you've ever
been
in our country of getting to that i
think we're closer i feel closer to that
i mean this is
absolutely it's it's beyond insulting
it's
it's oppressing the population so
there's a lot there
now before we get into the really crazy
part from tucker
don mclaughlin there the mayor of uvalde
texas said
illegal aliens are getting 1400 bucks
this is related to the stimulus package
that the number 1400 is not a
coincidence 1400 was what was in
the biden stimulus package the claim
they make
is undocumented immigrants are getting
1400
stimulus checks it's not true if an
immigrant is here illegally they won't
have a social security
number which you need to have in order
to get a stimulus check
biden's covet 19 relief package excludes
most immigrants who are not in the
united states legally from getting
stimulus checks
the relief packages during the trump era
did the same thing it's the same
there's no difference only non-citizens
who are here authorized to work
who can get a social security number can
get the stimulus
however according to some in the
associated press
some people who entered the u.s on valid
temporary working visas
which makes them eligible for a social
if they overstayed
they might accidentally get a for the
1400
this is a tiny number of people and it's
a distraction
and the idea that just any old and
undocumented immigrant is getting 1400
is completely wrong it's been widely
debunked but let's get to the really
wacky part this
real insurrection that tucker carlson
wants this is very dangerous
now i am very close to a free speech
absolutist and what i mean by that is i
believe any speech that is not actually
illegal is legal and thus should be
allowed period
is that legal that's a call for violence
it's a real call for violence it's a
clear call for violence
it's not subtle it's not using coded
language
this type of thing is the actually
illiberal anti-democratic authoritarian
threat that we've been talking about
what immigrants get 1400 uh
i don't even know if that's true but
what about a real insurrection yes let's
do it why not
right and then you go back to those
claims made in court by some of the
trump writers from january 6th fox news
made me do it your honor sir
my client was suffering from foxitis and
foxmania and fox dementia
it's not really their fault and as
outrageous
as we've been saying it is for the party
of personal responsibility to say
that thing i did it was trump and fox's
fault
well no you deserve to be held
accountable
but then when tucker says how about a
real insurrection
you genuinely are starting to muddy it
up
and make it even more complex to
apportion blame and responsibility now
one last thing
if such an insurrection happened thanks
to tucker carlson
tucker carlson's not going to be on the
front lines leading it you understand
that right tucker will be at his country
club or
uh at his v vacation home tucker is like
trump
in that they both value their viewers
and supporters respectively
as far as they are useful to them but
these people the people that voted for
trump
donated to trump rioted for trump on
january 6
the people that watched tucker and would
be likely to do what he says when he
says what about a real insurrection
these are the people that tucker like
trump spent their lives
trying to stay away from and be isolated
from they don't care about those people
beyond their immediate utility either
for ratings
or buying tucker's book has tucker
written a book i don't know or voting
for trump or donating to trump or
whatever the case may be and in that way
tucker and trump are actually very
similar they're disgusted by their
followers
they have disdain for their followers
but they understand that these are the
people that ultimately are responsible
for
writing the checks that keep them in
power or whatever the case may be
disgusting stuff and almost as
disgusting as this next thing we're
going to look at
radical right-wing media outlet o-a-n
is attempting to resurface from the
bottom of the trash heap
and they are doing so with a so-called
exclusive
interview with donald trump which is
really indistinguishable from north
korean propaganda
all of the same tired lies were
resuscitated
the really wacky intangible here is the
performance of the interviewer whose
name is chanel rion
we really can't tell this apart from one
of those north korea propaganda
interviews now first check out just the
introduction to the interview
and the first line of the interview it's
desperately sycophantic
this doesn't even count as journalism
even in the us and our journalism
standards are really low
really really low take a look at this
president donald j
trump left an indelible mark on u.s
politics
from the 25th floor of his iconic new
york headquarters
one america news sat down with our 45th
president
for an exclusive one-on-one discussion
there he shared with us his forecast his
fears and his hopes for america's
horizon
in the process we witness an
illuminating snapshot into the mind of a
man
whose leadership in battles sparked a
movement
that forever altered the course of
american history
this is an oan exclusive interview from
new york city new york
mr president we sit here in trump tower
many days and many miles
from what many americans consider an
illegitimate biden white house
in the first line of the introduction
she has to mention
biden isn't a legitimate president as
many people see it
mr president when you crowbar
illegitimate biden
into the opener you know it's going to
be utterly insane and it got way wackier
when trump started talking here is
donald trump ranting about a so-called
third world election in the united
states
and channel rion just chanel rion just
can't help
uh but uh can't help but try pushing
that same thing about oh fraud any day
now we're going to uncover the fraud
and if we can't convince people that
that won't
happen again or if we don't get right
down to the bottom of it and change it
those people aren't going to be there to
vote so the republicans
the republicans are going to have to do
something whether it's mitch mcconnell
or kevin mccarthy
or the leadership locally they have to
do something
there was a an expression that i've
heard that you've heard for
many years the vote counter is far more
important than the
politician or the person running for
office and that was the case in this
instance for the presidential election
very sad
that this could happen it was a third
world election well it looks like
a lot of that may well be uncovered very
shortly
being uncovered hopefully we'd see that
and it'd be nice if the papers would
report it
there is so much going on here first of
all
on the technical level why is the audio
always terrible with these oan
interviews the amount of room noise
background noise
our tech is a disaster we never have a
background noise issue like that like
i i have no idea what i'm doing but my
interviews never sound like that how can
oan in an interview with the president
not make it sound reasonable what i'm
realizing
is that an interview with a real anchor
or journalist and trump
it's already wacky just because of the
things that donald trump says
but at least when there's a sort of real
interviewer the questions can sometimes
get back on track there can sometimes be
an attempt to hold donald trump
accountable for what he's saying
what chanel rion from oan is doing is
participating in the shared delusions
with donald trump
trump says crazy stuff about fraud and
instead of asking for receipts
she asks uh she adds to it by saying
oh yeah any day now we're going to
uncover the fraud here's another piece
of this in which donald trump again
claims to have blockbuster technology
coming
this is great because for months he
touted a new digital communication
social media platform
that he was going to be launching and
instead he just launched a blog
it's just like blogspot technology
installed on his website
and now again he's teasing he has
something really big coming
so we had a couple hundred million
people
and the problem is a lot of these
platforms you can't put that many people
on it just doesn't work
they explode if you put 500 000 on
it's like a lot and they can't handle it
and the technology just isn't there
right now for that
but the technology is coming very
rapidly and we're working on something
that i think will be a blockbuster when
it happens it's going to be something
that's going to be
special but you know uh i've been
offered companies for
almost nothing big chunks of companies
that have platforms the problem is they
can't hold the people
yeah the platforms out there just can't
handle the amount of people that want to
follow trump
what facebook can't hold trump's
audience
twitter can't hold trump's audience
youtube can't hold it
these are delusions of the highest level
and chanel rion is just helping him
along
and then we get to the point of the
interview where trump again claims the
election results aren't possible
he just doesn't believe that he lost so
obviously it must be fraud what people
want to talk about
is it all comes down to what happened in
the election
because you look at georgia georgia was
fantastic what happened to all those
votes
what happened to all those people that
were standing on the line
wearing red hats and wearing all sorts
of things that what happened
and then you look at michigan and you
look at how do you win ohio in a record
in florida in a record in south carolina
in a record
in iowa and a record and then you lose
michigan
and you lose pennsylvania we were up at
10 30 in the evening by so much in
pennsylvania it wasn't doable
unless something crooked happened it is
abundantly
clear that he will never move past this
he still hasn't accepted that he lost
the popular vote in 2016.
he will never admit that he lost in 2020
and it's the same talking points now six
months out from the election
we were leading at 10 p.m and suddenly
there were these massive dumps of
ballots and then we were losing
it's over and over and over again the
same
talking point let's look at just one
more clip and then we'll move on
trump asked about joe biden on china
what was biden's first mistake here we
go see if you can understand this
china what was biden's first mistake
well i think he made many mistakes
number one he's shown such weakness you
know they have planes flying over taiwan
now
they never had this you know they never
had these problems you wouldn't have had
this problem in israel
they didn't shoot rockets when i was
there they were shooting thousands of
rockets into israel
that wouldn't have happened with me well
within four years your administration
brokered historic peace deals in the
middle east and within four months
the biden administration essentially has
is overseeing
a war just total fantasy world views of
how things work
biden showed weakness but then he says
something about israel instead
the question was about china now i do
think there are people
who see interviews like this and
they do think trump has an idea what
he's talking about
that's the really scary part and we know
that that's the case because 74 million
people voted for the guy
but it's really something else how vapid
and meaningless what he says is and
having a reporter
help him along as chanel rion did in
this
it's very dark for what it portends
about journalism in the united states
if you can even really still call this
journalism and
i don't think you can let me know what
you think
very depressing and bizarre interview
the david pakman show is now on
instagram at david pakman show you can
check out
behind the scenes pictures memes
shots of the studio shots of what pat
does all day very very concerning to a
lot of people
all of that and more on the david pakman
show instagram account at david pakman
show
so we've had a lot of bad news and kind
of things to be bummed out about on
today's show but one thing that really
brought a smile to my face was joe
biden's white house press secretary jen
saki
just not caring anymore when it comes to
fox news reporter peter ducey
and pointing out to him that the jig is
up
she realizes that the dumb questions
peter ducey asks during press briefings
are just to try to get one of those
absurd segments on fox news where the
title around the bottom of the screen is
some kind of
an attack either on joe biden or on gen
sake herself
and so she's just not going for it and
peter ducey tried to ask this completely
meaningless question
saying oh you know with trump it was the
art of the deal but with joe biden it
was going to be this other thing related
to infrastructure negotiations
and saki was just having none of it take
a look at this
describe the infrastructure negotiations
as the art of seeking common ground
at some point does that become the art
of the deal i don't know i
you're the professional here peter
you're the tv star
you know what's the fox chiron gonna be
uh art of seeking common ground does
take a lot of characters
we'd be okay with that yeah with the art
of the deal i think that's a headline
well there you go part of the of a
different kind of deal a deal for the
working people
got it okay go ahead so i'm glad we
could work that out thank you very much
the feel of peter ducey's questions
is that he's trying to play reporter and
jen saki humors him almost like he's not
really competent
but she just has to pretend to treat him
as if he were a competent reporter and
the really funny thing
is i think he's supposed to be seen as
asking tough questions like what he when
he does this stuff
i think there's a contingent of the fox
news audience that sees that and says
wow he's really there and he's asking
tough questions
but the questions are so silly and
childish
and not actually serious in any way
that jen gensake and even joe biden
seem to enjoy taking questions from
peter like if it were actually the case
that this guy was asking such tough
questions and putting them in such
difficult positions
they wouldn't be so eager to hear from
him they almost seem entertained by it
and it's almost a curiosity to see what
flaccid nonsense
peter ducey's going to come up with next
and you get the feeling that gensake
treats peter ducey and in some cases
that newsmax reporter named emerald who
was in the room
last week or the week before she's sort
of treating them
like you treat one of your kids when
they're having a temper tantrum and she
has young kids
you humor it you allow them to say the
thing they want to say
and then you move on while showing that
it's not really something
mommy is impressed with and that's the
that's the vibe i get
from gensake during these moments now
after this failed
peter ducey tries again apparently with
a quote real question it doesn't really
go much better
it's almost sometimes when he's reading
his questions like he's struggling to
understand because the emphasis and the
syntax
seems strange i don't really know let's
take a look
quickly on immigration the governor of
tennessee says that he was asked and he
declined a biden administration request
to house unaccompanied minors and in
coming days or in recent days there have
been
some reports that at least four planes
filled with unaccompanied minders
landed in his state some in the middle
of the night
can you explain what's going on there
well as we have been very clear about
children our objective is to unite these
unaccompanied children
children under the age of 18 with
families with sponsor families so
children
traveling through we're traveling
through have been traveling through
tennessee
uh they're simply on their way to unite
with relatives and sponsors to meet
sponsors in the state or just traveling
through tennessee
until they reach another destination to
unite with family members or
legal sponsors as you know
geographically it's
right in a place where you know there's
a lot of states around it
so it's a place where some flights have
gone through as uh children are moving
to other destinations
and since this was something that the
governor of the state said he didn't
want this is not
a case of federal officials trying to
sneak something past
the state level officials i i think i'm
confirming here that
tennessee is a state that is right near
in the middle of the country and some
kids have to travel
through there to get through their
destination and we've been very clear
that our objective is to
treat these kids humanely get them to
safe homes especially
homes of loved ones and sponsored
families
this is an attempt at a new fake
scandal which is the tennessee governor
doesn't want
any of biden's migrant children
traveling through
the state of tennessee but the tennessee
governor was silent about this
when it was trump doing the same thing
ducey's question of course
ignores that relevant context and yet
some flights have stopped in tennessee
in moving migrant children around
these are government flights mostly
stopping mostly at government air bases
and ducey wants to gin up a controversy
that joe biden is ignoring the requests
of the tennessee governor
the reality is that a flight stopping in
tennessee
for people to change planes or to
reunite with their families who may be
living in tennessee
it's not really the spirit of what the
tennessee governor is even talking about
and this is again mostly the federal
government using their airplanes
and airport resources available at their
disposal but it's supposed to be another
scandal and hilariously they then moved
on
to this was being done secretly check
out this headline from a recent episode
of hannity on fox news called
biden administration secretly flying
migrant children
into tennessee report says now again
secretly
when these are government planes going
to military bases
airports at military bases is it secret
that it's just
not like oh it's united flight 5 from
new york to la
uh to call it secret is also a stretch
it couldn't be more deceptive
the reality is that the biden
administration is
just like the trump administration
continuing to use geographically
convenient airports around the country
for layovers for children in their
custody
and the priority should be reuniting
those kids with their families which by
the way
the number of kids who have not yet been
reunited
is down 84 last month under the biden
administration it's not yet a victory
immigration has not been solved daca has
not been dealt with
but this is at least some progress from
what we were seeing under the trump
administration
administration the reuniting
of the children with their families
might most conveniently be done in
tennessee or with a layover in tennessee
it's very simple
everything is a scandal now and of
course unfortunately
none of them are really catching on as
scandals
but it doesn't matter because there's
this
general idea from the right if you watch
fox news
that joe biden is beleaguered and
riddled in scandal
individually none of the scandals really
catch on
but you still are starting to see
reflected in polling the idea that biden
is just
embroiled in scandal among fox news
viewers and republican voters so
this stuff works there's a reason why
they keep doing this stuff as you and i
might see it and say another fake
scandal this is trash
this is meaningless it actually does
work to convince a lot of people
so there are uh a number of stories
related to 2020 voter fraud that we will
be covering tomorrow
and i have one for today and uh
the the story is still all about
voter fraud for the 2020 election you
might be thinking wow david
it's almost june they must be talking
about voter fraud in some local election
that was last month
no they're still talking about recounts
audits voting machines
about the november 2020 election okay
zachary petrizo from salon
has a wild twitter thread which outlines
how
my pillow ceo and trump crony mike
lindell
claims to have physically obtained
dominion and smartmatic voting machines
apparently used in the 2020 election he
claims to commit
fraud in that election and is hiding the
machines
around the country almost like some
weird geocaching
check out this complete absurdity
zachary patrizo writing quote my pillow
ceo mike lindell is now claiming
he has not only obtained both dominion
and smartmatic voting machines
but also has hidden the machines in
secret locations around the country
okay so that's already bonkers off the
wall stuff
goes on to say quote according to a mike
lindell assistant who just spoke with
salon
the pillow maven is currently flying
somewhere
now and is unable to comment on the
matter
then it gets even wilder saying that
quote according to public information i
can confirm that lindell
is now flying aboard his private jet
tail number
n497sp which took off from
new bedford massachusetts and appears to
be heading west at this time
unclear if he is traveling with a voting
machine
they actually have the receipts from the
flights finding out that
quote lindell made a very quick stop at
elmira corning airport in horse heads
new york
and is now on his way back to bedford
new bedford massachusetts
remains unclear if a machine is riding
in hor hiding in horse heads
and why it was such a fast trip this is
almost like a bizarre
backwards scavenger hunt of some kind
how much of this new nonsense of lindell
flying around claiming to have voting
machines how much of this is going to
come out in the civil suit against
michael and dell by dominion voting
systems by the way
if he did obtain voting machines who did
he get him from if you get an extra firm
my pillow pillow and it's a bit too firm
maybe there's a voting machine in there
i received an email from a viewer
saying david don't you realize what's
going on this is mike lindell
starting to lay the groundwork for an
insanity defense
no no no no no lindell is a narcissist
like trump
they don't think they can get caught
they don't believe
they will get in trouble could this be
the explanation for the recent ufo uap
stuff that's been much discussed could
it be mike lindell
launching voting machines around the
skies no i don't believe so
will they ever be done and satisfied
with the 2020 election and the voting
machine stuff
probably not probably not but this is
the latest mike lindell reportedly now
has voting machines in his possession
really wild times we live in really wild
and depressing
we have a voicemail number you can call
that number anytime
that number is 2192
david p two one nine two
david p here is a delightful caller
monday i'm trying to keep it positive
with delightful callers
this is a delightful caller who got
coveted multiple times
she says and is just thrilled to finally
be vaccinated take a listen
hi david this is nancy from utah and i
just wanted to tell you how excited i
was to get my vaccine
um i got covered twice i wrote positive
once in september and once in january
and got quite sick both times so i was
thrilled to go get my vaccine i couldn't
be more pleased
to finally not have to worry about covet
again i must be some kind of freaky kova
magnet
love your show bye-bye thank you so much
i'm so glad to hear that i'm really
sorry that you had covered twice
um listen we've we have the tools my
friends we have the tools to crush this
virus we have vaccines that work against
the variants we've just got to use them
and we've got to use them quickly
and we'll have an update a little bit
later this week
about where we are as far as vaccines go
but
things i i know that there's still a lot
of doom and gloomers
but europe is opening travel is
restarting
kids are going back to school in the
fall uh
college students at many schools will be
required to be vaccinated there are some
businesses now saying our employees will
have to be
vaccinated to come back and uh do
in-person
work um we look at the numbers that
we're seeing
in countries that are achieving even
modest levels of vaccination look at our
cases
we've only fully vaccinated 37 in the
united states
okay and we are crushing the
the numbers they're still too high but
they're the lowest they've been in a
really long time we are probably
20 days from being at 50 fully
vaccinated
look at what happened in israel when
they got to 50
fully vaccinated there are good things
coming up
and we should all be happy about that
and we should all follow cdc guidelines
as i continue to do we have a great
bonus show for you today
um the house republican uh
house republicans many house republicans
are being
fined more and more money for not
wearing their masks which are still
required on the house floor marjorie
taylor green
has been fined and others have been
fined will they pay the fines is the
question we're going to talk about that
um a viral video well known to many in
our audience
on youtube is leaving youtube and
instead will be selling as an nft a
non-fungible token is this the future
of youtube videos very interesting
and lastly rick santorum has been fired
by cnn and it was over those comments
where he was caught saying
uh there was nothing of value here in
the united states
when the european settlers arrived like
other than all those native american
civilizations
very ugly and also non-real uh
not non-empirically based comments and
cnn has now fired rick santorum
republicans are saying it's cancelled
culture
canceled sort of like they did to liz
cheney for saying
trump really lost so we are going to
talk about that
on the bonus show as well become a
member
today to get instant access by signing
up at joinpackman.com
or we're only one week away from our
memorial day
membership bomb single day membership
special
be notified of it by signing up
at davidpakman.com for my newsletter
monday morning
the 31st you'll get a beautiful email
from me personally saying
hey you know what here's how you do it
here's how you sign up
for that hugely discounted membership
all right we'll talk to you on the bonus
show in mere moments
we are here all week we are off monday
memorial day i'm gonna be so busy
processing these massive membership
dumps we can't possibly do a show no and
we like giving the staff
federal holidays off alright see
everybody on the bonus show or tomorrow